*Intro music from the Walking Dead*
Wanna know when the zombie threat in "The Walking Dead"will end?
The producers have been leaving you clues since the very beginning.
But today, we put it all together.
Hello internet, welcome to Film Theory!
The brainiest YouTube series dedicated to film in TV.
Which, unfotunately, makes us a prime target come the zombie apocalypse.
So you can bet I've been watching "The Walking Dead", taking notes on how to survive in the event of that happens.
Over six seasons, "The Walking Dead" has remained the biggest show on television by constantly re-inventing itself.
Like in season 2, when Rick and Carl sought refuge at a farm.
At first, Hershel and Rick didn't get along,
but after a while they came to understand one another.
Everything was great, until zombies raided the farm,
forcing Rick and Carl to flee.
Or like the time in season 3 & 4 when Rick and Carl sought refuge at a prison.
At first, the prisoners and Rick didn't get along,
but then after a while they came to understand one another.
Everything was great, until zombies raided the prison, forcing Rick and Carl to flee.
Or like the time in season 5 & 6 when Rick and Carl sought refuge in Alexandria
At first, Rick and Alexandrians didn't get along,
but after a while they came to understand one another.
Everything was great, until zombies raided Alexandria forcing Rick and Carl to...
Huh, maybe I was a bit too hasty saying "re-inventing" itself.
All routing aside though, are Rick, Carl and the rest
doomed to reenact the goriest version  of "Groundhog Day"
over and over again until they get careless and wind up trapped under a dead man in a zombie swarm?
I mean, look how excited we got when Eugene said he had found a cure to the outbreak, and then...
we see how well that panned out...
Are these survivors going to save
the world by the end of the series?
Hate to break it to you, but no, no they won't.
They're just average survivors trying to get by,
not super-humans saving the world.
But that's not to say they'll be
permanently stuck in a zombie hellscape.
In fact, I'm here to tell you today that the zombies won't be posing a threat much longer on The Walking Dead.
That's right! Zombies are going extinct!
And that expiration date is approaching
far sooner than you may realize!
Now first, I need to address one big caveat;
not all zombies were made at the same time.
Turning into a zombie is contingent on 2 factors: When you die and/or when you're bitten.
But it is important to note that the overwhelming number of The Walking Dead zombies were turned in the first two months of the outbreak.
How do we know this? Well, Rick wakes up two months after the outbreak began,
and the world's already descended into a complete post-apocalyptic wasteland,
with only clusters of survivors left.
Cities are empty!
You can go weeks without
coming across another survivor.
And as we learned from doctor Jenner
at the CDC at the end of the season,
this is also true for the rest of the world.
Even France is overrun by zombies!
"It was the French."
"What?"
"They were the last ones to hold out as far as I know."
Now, zombies gain their
power through sheer numbers.
It's these hordes that have plagued the remaining survivors from the very first episode,
where Rick gets trapped in a tank
surrounded by zombies,
to the most recent season, where Rick gets trapped in an RV... surrounded by zombies.
But as much as I joke about repeated
tropes in the series,
it's these swarms that have shown
the most reliable changes,
and these changes are our biggest clue to the way
the whole series will end.
Look closely at the evolution in the design of the zombie hordes across the seasons of the show.
We start Season 1 with everyone pale
and fairly well intact.
By Season 3 and 4 they're looking pretty rough,
and Seasons 5 and 6, these guys are faces only a zombified mother could love.
Very clearly, the creative team of The Walking Dead has been consciously making the human zombies
gradually look more and more grotesque every season.
It's a conscious choice.
But why?
Well, it's not just for scare tactics. They're doing it because these zombies are actually decomposing,
and like everything that decomposes, eventually they'll be nothing more than a bundle of bones and dust.
Based on this information we can predict a
timeline for when this series will end.
Decomposition of a body is broken down
into 5 general stages:
Initial Decay, Putrefaction, Black Putrefaction
Butyric Fermentation, and Dry Decay.
Over the course of The Walking Dead's six seasons,
the zombie hordes have slowly progressed
through these stages.
In the first Season, the zombies showed symptoms often associated with initial decay,
or as it's referred to, the "Fresh Stage" of decomposition
SUBWAY, eat fresh!
After the heart stops beating, the body goes into a complete meltdown,
breaking down on the cellular level.
During this "Fresh Stage", the body's temperature drops.
Since the heart's stopped beating, all remaining blood in the body drains to the lower portions.
The skin gets tighter, turns grey.
The eyes begin to sink into the skull.
In the first season of Walking Dead, most
zombies we see fulfil a lot of these qualities.
The first zombie Rick encounters is
a grey little girl with sunken eyes.
The zombie horde Rick hides from
in the tank are also, you guessed it--
pale with sunken eyes.
Zombies from Season 2 through 5 of
The Walking Dead are emblematic
of the second stage of decomposition:
Putrefaction - often referred to as "The Bloat Stage".
And it's not because they're feeling bloated after
eating a bunch of carbs.
Remember--these guys are a bunch of protein eaters. No, it's because
gases start to accumulate in the body,
causing it to swell,
especially around the face.
The eyes and tongue in particular,
start to protrude outwards.
We're not quite to Arnold Schwarzenegger "Total Recall" levels of the eye popping-ness,
but we're close.
The gases that accumulate in the body
have nowhere to go,
causing ruptures and tears in the skin
much the same as the ProActiv-challenged skin of The Walking Dead Season 2 and Season 3 zombie hordes.
It's also during this phase that the body's
skin tone becomes marbled,
revealing a pattern of blood vessels
in the face, abdomen, and chest.
Look across Season 3 and you find
yourself some "USDA Prime Marbling".
After two weeks, the skin becomes so loose
that it can easily be pulled off of a corpse.
Does that sound familiar?
In Season 5, Rosita grabs a zombie
out of the woods and, that's right,
pulls the skin right off.
Which brings us to the third stage of decomposition,
"Black Putrefaction",
which is even nastier than those
first two stages combined.
During Black Putrefaction,
or, as it's commonly referred to, "Active Decay",
the skin of the corpse turns black.
The corpse then flattens out like a penny, as all the gases escape.
The internal organs liquify,
turning the body into a soupy fluid.
MM-MM-MMH.
Coming soon to an overpriced Whole Foods near you.
Hey- its organic, alright?
In the past 6th season of The Walking Dead,
zombies show clear signs of finally entering
this 3rd stage of decomposition,
showing black discoloring of their face and torso.
You can also see - or, not see,
that the eyes of many of these zombies have completely liquified,
leaving black empty chasms in their place.
After this stage,  things get pretty dull.
During the fourth stage, Buteric Fermentation,
AKA "Advanced Decay",
the body and all remaining flesh dry out.
And then finally, during the fifth stage,
"Dry Decay", all that remains of the body
is just the bundle of bones.
Now, you loyal theorists may be wondering,
"How do you time these post-mortem changes?"
"It's not like people just lay bodies out in an open field and then watch them slowly decompose, right?"
Well, actually that's exactly what happens.
They're called "body farms".
But instead of growing plants, vegetables or fruit,
forensic investigators plant dead bodies,
and then watch them decompose over time.
Which, little known fact, is 10 times more exciting than watching Season 2 of The Walking Dead.
*Crickets chirping*
Body farms aid investigators in solving murders,
and establishing a time frame for the deceased.
From this research, we know that the first stage of decomposition generally occurs between zero
to three days post death.
Putrefaction occurs four to ten days,
Black Putrefaction in 10 to 20 days,
Butyric Fermentation within 20 to 50 days,
and the 5th stage, Dry Decay takes
between 50 and 350 days post-death.
There are a number of factors, though, that actually increase
this rate of decomposition in a cadaver.
First and foremost--
exposure to the elements.
According to "Casper's Law of Decomposition"
- wait, are you serious?
Casper? Casper like the friendly ghost?
Who comes up with these names?
Scientists, real talk.
I love the nerdy tongue-and-cheek
naming conventions that you use,
but sometimes its really hard to take you seriously
when you're naming laws after
children's cartoon characters,
or proteins after Sonic the Hedgehog.
Anyway, "Casper's Law of Decomposition" states, quote,
that "A body left in the open air decomposes twice as fast as if it were immersed in water...
...and eight times faster than if it were buried underground." end quote.
So those zombies, just by rising up out of the ground,
have increased their rate of decomposition, eight-fold!
The second key factor here is temperature.
Heat accelerates the rate of cellular breakdown
and increases the rate of putrefaction.
The hotter and more humid the temperature,
the quicker the body will decompose.
So obviously, the zombies on the show
aren't decaying at the rate of a typical human body,
but what exactly is this zombie decay rate?
The Walking Dead, up to Season 6,
has taken place over 552 days
since the zombie outbreak began.
A typical human cadaver would
have decomposed twice over,
at LEAST, at this point.
So given that Season 6 depicts
zombies in the latter days
of Black Putrefaction--
blackened skin, liquified organs--which tends to happen
around 20 days post death in a normal cadaver,
we can use this as correlative evidence to predict when complete zombie decay will occur.
If 20 days equals the typical amount of time for a cadaver to reach Black Putrefaction,
and the same process for The Walking Dead
zombies is 552 days.
Then using some simple math,
20 over 552 equals 50 over X
The unknown complete Dry Decay for a zombie.
We can predict that the zombies will
have completely decayed
in 1,380 days.
This would be the complete life cycle
of a zombie on The Walking Dead.
Which means that we still have 828 days,
a little over two years, until the zombies become
nothing more than just dried up bones.
Now, I know what you're thinking,
"So what? Two years? That's a really long time!"
"Look what's happened in just
a year and a half on the show."
"Plus, then the zombies would
just be skeleton zombies."
By then The Walking Dead will be hiring Ray Harryhausen.
Sorry, that was an obscure reference.
Ray Harryhausen was a pioneer of stop motion animation,
and perhaps his most famous scene is a skeleton battle that happens
in the movie Jason and the Argonauts.
NOW YOU KNOW!
It's one of those lesser known pieces of cinematic history
that definitely deserves some celebration, so
worth mentioning here.
But that being said, The Walking Dead
isn't Jason and the Argonauts.
The one thing that keeps the zombies
going isn't their skeletal bodies,
it's their brains.
And it probably comes as no surprise
that its not just the external body that
decomposes post death,
but internal organs do, too.
And so, when in the decomposition
timeline does the brain
liquify? Black Putrefaction.
The very stage the zombie horde is currently in.
Rick doesn't have to shoot or stab a zombie
in the head to kill it.
He just has to wait for nature to take its course.
Step 1: Find another prison.
Step 2: Build a stronger fence.
Step 3: Profit!!!
So how long should Rick expect to be a dirty camper?
At the CDC in Season 1, Dr. Jenner shows them the
onset of a zombie. Per Dr. Jenner,
zombies don't function on the entirety of their brain,
just the brain stem.
"The frontal lobe, the neo-cortex, the human part,
that doesn't come back."
Thus, it's not even the entirety of the
brain that needs to decompose,
just the stem.
In a typical cadaver at room temperature,
this process would take a month, tops.
If 20 days equals the typical amount of time for a
cadaver to reach Black Putrefaction,
and this same process for the Walkers is 552 days,
then using the same formula --
20 over 552 equals 30 over X,
the amount of time for zombie brain melting,
the brains in zombies will completely melt in 828 days.
Subtracting out the time that's
already happened on the show,
Rick and the gang only have to survive 276 more days
until the majority of zombie horde brains
turn to complete mush.
However, this decay rate isn't accounting for
the temperature, the humidity,
or the exposure to the outside.
All of which increase the rate of
decomposition tremendously.
So using Casper's Law of Decomposition,
we can predict that this process
will happen at least 8 times faster
in the world of the show.
Which means that the survivors
have a little over a month,
34 days, until the zombie brains
turn into pea soup and their
lifeless corpses will be just that.
Lifeless corpses once more.
If that isn't enough, look no further than
the show itself.
This past season has been set
over the course of two days.
Never before has the show jammed so much stuff
into a 48-hour period.
Why would the show slow its timeline down so much?
Because the creators themselves know that the
zombies are on borrowed time.
If you need more proof, look at the location.
Alexandria, Virginia
According to the Köppen Climate Classification System,
Alexandria is classified by hot, humid summers
and has a sub-tropical climate.
So you would think that the zombies would decompose
quicker there, but remember
Rick and the gang came from Atlanta Georgia,
where Seasons 1 through 4 were set.
A substantially hotter and more humid climate.
You think it's a coincidence that Rick and Carl
are moving to colder temperatures?
In Georgia, the zombies would probably have fully decomposed by now.
The only way the writers can justify continuing
the show is by a), slowing down the timeline to a halt
and b), moving the show to colder temperatures
where zombies will decompose slower.
So get ready for The Walking Dead Season 15
set over the course of 1 hour in a blizzard in Antarctica.
Try as hard as you want AMC writers,
but there's no stopping the inevitable.
It's not a question of if the zombies will go extinct,
but a matter of when. Time is a zombie's
biggest killer, and soon time will end the zombie threat.
And The Walking Dead as we know it.
But hey, that's just a theory,
a FILM THEORY!
AAAAND CUT!
And before you go, did you know that The Walking Dead
has hidden references to the Roman Empire
sprinkled throughout its
various seasons? It's true!
The parallels are actually fascinating.
If you want to find out more, click here
to check out a brand new video from my friends
over at Wise Crack
where they are picking apart the series
to uncover the deeper meaning
hidden under its fleshy folds.
In fact, here you go. Click their logo to check out
the whole channel.  If you're a fan
of my theories, then you're gonna love their interpretations of all things
pop culture from The Matrix to Rick and Morty.
So head on over and tell 'em MatPat sent ya.
They'll appreciate it.
And finally in case you missed it a couple weeks ago,
here's a link to another theory
I did on The Walking Dead.
Exploring how, technically,
everyone on the series should be DEAF.
Not dead, deaf.
It means Rick and the gang are literally the walking deaf.
(ba-doom ching)
So there you go, some good options for you.
And remember guys, That's JUST a THEORY.
A FILM THEORY!